with all the chaos the biden regime is
creating in afghanistan at the border in
congress it's easy to overlook the
smaller things that actually explain the
big things so i want to take a moment to
focus on one of the most disgusting
comments made by any democrat on any
topic this week or in fact for a long
time it came from jen saki here it is
there are some and i'm not sure if this
is the case in this report who argue
that in the past
companies have passed on these costs to
consumers i'm not sure if that's the
argument being made in this report
we feel that that's unfair and absurd
what you just saw was the authentic
voice of the smug entitled out of touch
arrogant elite of someone who's never
created a single job in her entire life
and there's no clue about the stress and
struggle of starting and running a
business check out jen saki's resume on
wikipedia it's kind of amazing actually
mostly just one long list of deputy
press secretary and spokesperson and
communications director and whatever for
one democrat non-entity after another
over two entire decades the sum total of
jen saki's private sector experience is
a couple of years at swamp lobbying
firms and on cnn what does she know
about what it's like to actually run a
company scrabbling to put financing in
place finding good people making enough
money to pay them and take care of the
managing overheads and expenses getting
customers through the door fighting off
competitors worrying the whole time they
could all come crashing down and you're
accountable you're responsible i've done
that multiple times here in america back
in england how dare jen sarki call it
unfair and absurd for americans to try
and keep their businesses afloat in the
face of assaults from democrats stupid
cruel anti-enterprise policies what does
jen sarki know about any of this what do
any of them know
look at susan rice the clinton
administration the obama administration
the biden administration the brookings
institution the u.n
look at pelosi's career dnc member
northern california party chair
california party chair san francisco
convention host committee chair democrat
senatorial committee fundraising chair
member of congress for nearly 35 years
and of course biden the worst of them
all nothing but a leech on the wealth
creating engine of america for over 50
years he's never had a proper job in his
life oh apart from facing down corn pop
as a lifeguard one summer back in the
60s biden's been nothing but a machine
politician since he ran for county
council in delaware in 1970. these
people make me sick they think business
is just a piggy bank for government
schemes that feed their own vanity look
how bountiful we are giving money to
families and children aren't we good not
like those business people who are
unfair and absurd
what's unfair and absurd is jen saki
susan rice nancy pelosi biden they
understand go on about nurses and
doctors the heroes in the public sector
the teachers their donors by the way and
yes of course some public sector workers
really are heroes including the ones the
democrats constantly insult like police
officers but here are some other
americans who are heroes the small town
shopkeeper whose family business has
been at the heart of their community for
generations who was forced by the
democrats to close its doors while
target stayed open the local restaurant
owner who employs local kids and
sponsors little league the independent
auto mechanic who keeps our cars and
trucks on the road these are the heroes
who make everything else in america
possible not just through what they do
but because of the jobs they create the
wealth they create that's what pays for
everything else
these are the heroes who actually pay
gen saki's salary who pay for the job
security and luxury pensions of biden
and saki's precious public sector
gen revealed the true ugly face of
today's democrats they are the party of
the public sector for the public sector
and if you're not part of it you're
nothing to them it is truly contemptible
i'm steve ducey i'm brian killme and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis